the g factor only accounts for maybe
half or some amount on the test
performance for example i get
a
pretty bad test anxiety like i was never
i mean
i just don't enjoy tests i enjoy going
back into my cave and working like i've
always enjoyed homework
way more than tests
uh no matter how hard the homework is
because i can go back to the cave and
hide away and think deeply there's
something about being watched and having
a time limit that really makes me
anxious and i could just see the mind
not operating optimally at all but
you're saying underneath there there's
still a g factor there's the question
there's no no question ah boy
and if you get anxious taking the test
many people say oh i didn't do well
because i'm anxious yeah
you know i hear that a lot yeah well
fine if you're really anxious during the
test
the score will be a bad estimate of your
g factor yeah it doesn't mean the g
factor isn't there that's right and by
the way
standardized tests like the sat
they're essentially intelligence tests
they are highly g-loaded now the the
people who make the s.a.t don't want to
mention that
for obvious they have enough trouble
justifying standardized testing but to
call it an intelligence test is really
beyond the pale but in fact it's so
highly correlated because it's a
reasoning test sat is a reasoning test a
verbal reasoning mathematical reasoning
yeah and if it's a reasoning test it has
to be related
to to g but if people
go in and take a standardized test
whether it's an iq test or the sat and
they happen to be sick that day with
fever yeah the score
is not going to be a good estimate of
their g
if they retake the test when they're not
anxious or less anxious or don't have a
fever
the score will go up and that will be a
better estimate but you can't say their
g factor increased between the two tests
well it's interesting so the question is
how wide of a battery of tests is
required to estimate the g factor well
because i'll give you as my personal
example i took the sat
and i think it was called the act where
i was too also i took sat many times
every single time i got perfect on math
and verbal
the time limit on the verbal make me
very anxious
i did not i mean part of it i didn't
speak english very well
but honestly it was like you're supposed
to remember stuff and like i was so
anxious and like as i'm reading i'm
sweating i can't you know that like um
that feeling you have when you're
reading a book and you
you just read a page and you know
nothing about what you've read because
you zoned out that's the same feeling of
like
i can't i have to you you're like nope
read and understand and that anxiety is
like
and you start seeing like the typography
versus the content of the words like
that was
i i don't it's interesting because
um
i know that
what they're measuring i could see it
being correlated with with something
but that anxiety or some aspect of the
performance
um
sure plays a plays a factor and
i wonder how you sneak up in a stable
way i mean this is a broader discussion
about
that's like uh standardized testing how
you sneak up
how you get
at the fact that i'm super anxious and
still nevertheless measure some aspect
of my intelligence i wonder i don't i
don't know i don't know if you can say
it to that that time limit sure is a
pain well let me say this
there are two ways to approach the very
real problem that you say that some
people just get anxious or not good test
takers
by the way
part of
part of testing is
you know the answer you can figure out
the answer or you can't
right
if you don't know the answer there are
many reasons you don't know the answer
at that particular moment you may have
learned it once and forgotten it
you may it may be on the tip of your
tongue and you just can't get it because
you're anxious about the time limit you
may never have learned it
you may never you you may have been
exposed to it but it was too complicated
and you couldn't learn it i mean there
are all kinds of reasons here
but for an individual to interpret your
scores
as an individual
whoever is interpreting the score has to
take into account various things that
would affect your individual score and
that's why decisions about college
admission
or anything else where tests are used
are hardly ever the
only criterion
to make a decision
you